so k for chemist of course means
potassium the evil element but it also
of course means kelvin the absolute
temperature
and because i'm interested in how
materials behave at different
temperatures i've been very familiar
with kay in my doctoral work i did most
of my experiments at 20k
and so
i've always had a warm feeling from
kelvin there are all sorts of funny
stories about him
there's one story that he asked a class
of students what is electricity and one
student put up his hand
and when he asked what is it he said i'd
forgotten
and kelvin said this is a tragedy
there are only two people who know what
electricity is
one is god
and the other is mr makai who has
forgotten the reason why we have this
temperature scale
is because 0 kelvin absolute zero
is the coldest temperature which it is
theoretically possible to go to
so it is an absolute position of zero
you cannot actually ever get quite to
zero
kelvin but you can get within a
thousandth of a degree kelvin or even
lower
before that
people chose
zero for their temperature scale
by somewhere that was fairly arbitrary
well obviously um on the news they use
well they used to use the fahrenheit
temperature scale which is quite arcane
now although you can't say that to an
american um and essentially that's based
on very human scales that's based on a
measurement of human
body temperature
which is a slightly strange thing to use
as a unit in terms of physics fahrenheit
thought he would make zero the coldest
temperature he could get which was
mixing
snow and nitro concentrated nitric acid
so for him
ice melted at 32
and then he wanted to make a hundred
degrees the temperature of the human
body
but unfortunately he got it slightly
wrong or perhaps he had a fever that day
so in fact the normal temperature comes
out at 98.4
which is not terribly convenient but
then water boils at 212
degrees fahrenheit
so
when celsius came along
we came up with centigrade scale which
is exactly what it says on the tin it's
100
steps and the steps are taken from the
freezing point of water to the boiling
point of water so we have 100 steps and
100 being the boiling point of water so
the advantage of the degrees kelvin
is that
there is a theoretically justified
reason why you call
zero zero
nobody can get it colder so you can
never have a negative temperature in
degrees kelvin so this is the liquifier
for helium and the temperature that
we're talking about here is one two
degrees kelvin and at these temperatures
superconductivity and superfluidity come
in right so the reason that we have this
here at the university is because most
of our magnets that we use for things
like brain imaging and the various
levitation experiments that we like to
do they all use liquid helium to cool
the magnets down to super fluid
temperatures uh as you can see it's a
fairly big piece of technology
but what it all comes down to is this do
you want to do this or will i do this
right here we've got here we've got some
liquid helium watch it cooling down on
the nozzle here right it's slowly
cooling down quite rapidly cooling down
and then very quickly
ready
wait for it
here it comes right
and this is this is fabulous this is so
cold you've got to come and put your
hand in it but it's really great
experience